ihr seht es bereits den titel
eingeblendet eine wichtige info deswegen
will ich es auch direkt zu beginn dieses
videos machen und bevor der ganze block
losgeht ich will jetzt keine zeit
verlieren ist auch eine sehr kurze info
die allerdings wie bereits gesagt
wichtig ist und ich glaube ich jeden von
uns weiterbringen wird denn morgen wenn
die uhren umgestellt
das war's
ich weiß nicht was diese scheiße soll
aber vergesst das nicht
erst seit ihr nämlich alle eine stunde
zu spät in der schule ich habe mir
übrigens eine kamera gestellt die man um
sein
drum rum machen kann
und dann fängt die kamera alles aus der
perspektive also wir testen das mal
trust klappt super alle freuen sich mal
wegen dem wetter
außerhalb und die freuen sich wegen des
wetters warum wünscht man sich
eigentlich nur am ersten januar ein
frohes neues
ich meine nehmen wir mal an ich treff
nachher ein kumpel den ich zuletzt im
dezember gesehen habe und ich würde ihm
dann einfach mal zur begrüßung sagen hey
frohes neues das wäre mir
einfach nur weil schon ende märz aber
ich habe ihn seit letztem jahr nicht
mehr gesehen also vergesst mir
eigentlich auch immer drei jahre lang
das ihren sandwich maker habt ihr euch
drei wochen nur davon
auch nicht die beschissene frage der
welt ist übrigens was hast du eigentlich
für musik
das fragen nur psychopathen und vor
allem auch das wird es mit der antwort
anfangen
[Musik]
das ist kann einfach alles dunkler
geworden nur weil ich hier gegen
gelaufen bin wofür bereitest du das
alles vor
das anders auch schon hier mit ihren
schönen platz gefunden im park jetzt am
parkplatz mehr eimern als frisbee
spielen geht nicht
sagen wir uns mit sieben boxen auf einer
picknickdecke wenn man beim picknick ein
dick verschickt ist es dann romantisches
gedicht dahin ist die ganze zeit so ein
rasensprenger und er nervt um normal
aber warum heißt rasen sprengen man
springt doch nicht den rasen ist doch
keine bombe im uns nicht alle zeit
gefragt warum sie eigentlich so leer aus
einem park ich glaube das liegt daran
weil wir direkt neben dem flughafen sind
die ganze zeit extrem laute flugzeuge
starten alle spazieren eigentlich eine
freizeitaktivität geworden das ist
einfach nur gehen warum sagt man
eigentlich so spazieren gehen lasst mal
spazieren gehen dass man spazieren man
hängt noch das gähnen und dann stehst du
einfach so peinlich dass menschen so
krass abhängig vom wetter sind wo es
gutes wetter draußen die sonne scheint
das sehr gute laune us regel das heißt
ja schlechte laune
wir fahren so viele leute die er da
vorne hier um die fahren ja alleine rum
auf dem fahrrad oder e scooter einfach
nur mit einer box auf voller lautstärke
pro es gibt für
kopfhörer
dann sollten eigentlich so koren hörer
dann hätte ich nicht im kopf hat er mit
den orden held dieser opa der da vorne
gerade die jungs angemeckert hat dass
sie die musik leiser machen sollen das
echt so ein
also wegen spielt ja in diese menschen
die so plötzlich einfach ihre schuhe
ausziehen wenn sie die fühlen sich dann
mehr mit der erde verbunden das immer so
unangenehm wenn man dann so nach dem
picknick und nachdem man auf seiner
decke sei es dann wieder aufsteht und
man ist nur als alle anderen man ist
immer so dass man ist so man ist ja man
ist so geborgen irgendwie finde ich wenn
man so eins mit dem boden ist
ein paar blocks habe ich gesagt es gibt
keinen besseren geruch als benzin in der
garage ich muss mich da korrigieren wir
sind durch den park gelaufen es gibt
keinen geigerin geruch
grillkohle wehrleute gerade grill an
machen weil das offiziell heißt sommer
und essen seinen versuchen fitter
stammen
ich habe auch einen fetten stammen
erholte warum heißt eigentlich fahrstuhl
das ist ja kein stuhl besetzten
raum ist es eher heißen
neuer tag neues glück und sagt man dass
wobei neues glück ist es auf dem klo
bin ich auch heute war
auf dem weg ins gym feiert übrigens
immer auf der falschen straßenseite weil
es auf deiner seite einfach keine
richtigen fahrradwege und ich freue mich
immer so übertrieben wenn wir dann leute
entgegen kommen die keine deutschen sind
weil jeder deutsche mekka mitverwendet
ich habe die falsche straßenseite jetzt
empfohlen das peinlichste der welt
passiert jetzt nach zehn minuten
training aufgefallen dass man den
airports nicht verbunden waren
jeder konnte die kultur von jim hören
und als wir das dann aufgefallen jetzt
habe ich etwa die airports ganz schnell
aufgehoben und wollte sie verbinden und
dabei sind sie mir hingefallen und die
treppe runter
die ganzen negativen war es ist
allerdings dass man beiseite denn kate
und ich von heute an die ostsee
es ist 15 grad draußen sie werden
wahrscheinlich hinterher gebrauchen wir
fahren jetzt sie geradeaus über die
kennedybrücke das auch gut so weil ich
kenne die brücke warum macht man sich da
eine spinne hin wir sind am strand
angekommen und an den parkplätzen
ist nichts los
hier ist alles frei
aber vielleicht wenigstens am stand was
los
irgendwie sind wir die einzigen
weiß was passiert wenn ich die sonne
angucke dann
kommt ihnen schwitzen war ich 24 unter
vorne lag einfach hat die ganze zeit in
der sonne und schatten gelegt
wie nennt man rund tätigkeitsfeld in der
sonne lag
[Applaus]
ja ist wie die sonne alles muss ich mir
nur um dich du hast echt viele
gemeinsamkeiten mit der sonne
je länger man nicht anguckt ist um mehr
schmerzhaften augen
[Applaus]
nicht eigentlich ein
[Musik]
er verbrennt sich die sonne an mir haben
wisse wohin wolken fliegen wenn sie sich
offen zum wolkenkratzer es ist schon
echt idyllisch hier wenn nicht hinter
eine verdammte schnellstraße werden
ganze busse hier erfahren ich auch immer
so hunger wenn ihr mehr schwimmbad
strand wir waren jetzt sage und schreibe
an eineinhalb stunden hier
eine stunde sogar allerdings war adam so
kalt dass wir jetzt unseren trip
abbrechen mussten
ich wäre gerne noch länger geblieben
aber so ist es hier wohnt übrigens
peyton also eine lusche bild
[Musik]
sind so richtige dorf sachen gehört ja
eigentlich auch zu der generation die
damals mit den eltern nur mit einer
landkarte in den urlaub gefahren sind
ich kann ich meine landkarte lesen alter
manchmal besser mit damals die halbe
welt gefahren wir sind wieder zu hause
packen gerade die sachen aus und könnte
das wenn ihr einmal im strandbad
unternehmen gefühl zwei tonnen sand nach
hause
weiß eigentlich warum ist nordsee ostsee
heißt
richtig danke auch übrigen wieder eine
brieffreundschaft zuschauer die mir
wieder ein brief vor die tür geschlossen
haben diesmal allerdings noch in
kombination mit einem luca - scheiße
punkt.de kaugummi behälter und dann
leeren powerade flasche
korrekt kaufen kann ich es ist übrigens
freitagabend 21 uhr gekocht gehen jetzt
schlafen alle meine freunde sind raus
unterwegs party
ja du hast mich auf den boden wie nebel
am flughafen die flugzeuge ich bin hier
im beispiel im flugzeug und sie hält
mich vom fliegen ab nicht